[Music]
[Music]
all right people we are live on the
YouTube this is an impromptu livestream
this came together yesterday because
there are so many forces in the world
that are moving so freaking fast right
now and the man sitting across from me
has been tracking these things like a
like a what how are you tracking these
things like a mathematician like a
mathematician Eric Weinstein everybody
knows you already all right we got a lot
to do here
real quick I'm gonna go back to the
camera over there for just a second so
I'm gonna do about an hour and a half
with Eric we're gonna chat about all
kinds of stuff and then no I'm gonna
keep talking you so we're gonna do about
an hour and a half together and then
we're gonna do patreon only Q&A so only
the Reubens select people are gonna get
in on that patreon.com slash Reuben
report and any people that join at any
level will be able to ask us questions
directly no no censoring around here
great you alright with that
I am okay so the reason I wanted to do
this and we've been we've been trading a
lot of calls the last couple days and
the reason I was like we got to just do
this tomorrow is that I feel like I'm
living in kind of two worlds at the
moment that I've been on this tour with
Peterson for the last you know four
months or so we've done about 50 cities
you've appeared at some of the shows
where I've brought you on and you play
the harmonica and get the crowd going
and 3,000 people cheering as you're
playing the harmonica which I assume is
your your biggest great your greatest
professional joy so far but I'm meeting
quite literally thousands of people
every night in different cities all over
this country and soon to be all over the
world we're about to do 18 stops and in
Europe that are coming together over
ideas that are putting political
differences aside getting rid of it hate
trying to figure out some answers they
dig what what we're doing what's going
on with the IDW all of that then you go
on on Twitter and everywhere else online
and just the hate fest seems to have
been ramped up and it's not just Twitter
I always talk about it in a Twitter
perspective but just everything the
articles of hating this one hating that
one all this stuff with Kavanagh
everyone these siloing of opinions has
just increased exponentially and it all
seems to be getting worse and that
brings me to why you're sitting here
because you came on this show about two
years ago for the first time we had just
met a little bit before that
and we started talking about fake news
just as it was bubbling up and I think
some of your predictions that you laid
out were kind of right and I suspect
that maybe you have a couple answers to
some of the theories that you that you
dropped back then how was that for an
intro well Einstein is it's a lot of
that matches my own experience and I do
think that these these parallel worlds
are very confusing if you've never seen
what I've termed the vampire effect so a
vampire is supposed to not reflect in a
looking-glass when it passes by and in a
in essence the shows that you're doing
with Jordan are vampiric that at some
level they don't really exist he can
produce people coming together
extraordinary impacts in people's lives
he can talk about his disdain for
reactionary movements and it doesn't
change the narrative at all and so it's
some level there are two jordan
Peterson's there are two Dave Reubens it
may even be two Eric Weinstein's but I'm
a smaller fish in this in this pond and
one of them is a fictional character
that is drawn using details of your
actual life and the other is your actual
life so one's just the media caricature
basically but but it's a very
interesting caricature in other words
it's as if somebody has affixed strings
to your hands into your feet and so
every time you make a motion your
character has to move so you have to
start doing these calculations if I say
something a little bit nuanced I have to
run the risk that it will be taken out
of context in my media character will
end up saying something that I I find
absolutely abhorrent and so the goal is
to get you to consider the consequences
of your actions if I tell you that every
action you could take would be mapped to
some consequence that I will write into
a story then you start thinking okay
it's not question of what I want to do
it's a question of what do I want to do
given the fact that you're going to
carry it
so do you think that these even if their
self-imposed constraints have now been
placed on many people about how they
speak and really how they think and how
they act
you think it's significantly worse now
than it was even two years ago well
because right before the election you
had all these people saying oh you know
the polls were off because all the Trump
people let's say didn't want to say what
they really thought it seems like those
screws have been tightened even more so
I'm not I don't mean it just in a
certain context in one one through one
lens things have gotten much worse but
I'm actually in a kind of a different
mood about all of this now which is I
would say that when I first came on I
was quite cautious and I said that this
fake news mean if you will
felt very inauthentic Trump had just won
the election in November of 2016 and my
interpretation at the time which hasn't
changed much was that the people who had
lost control of the major narratives
realized that they needed to buy time to
figure out how they were going to
re-establish narrative control and so
what they did was they created a shell
in my opinion that they were gonna have
to fill as they had meetings and figured
out what they wanted to do and that
shell was fake news so basically by
pushing the idea of all the Trump voters
we're paying attention to fake news
that's what caused them to vote for
Trump right well so you had this problem
which is that when you have to call 50%
of your electorate deplorable because
they're voting for someone beyond the
pale now keep in mind I think it's
absolutely essential that we unelect
Trump as soon as possible so I've called
him an existential risk from before the
election and I continue to do what
everything I can do honorably and
decently to figure out how to unelect
him you were a Bernie guy well I was a
Bernie guy in the sense that I voted for
Bernie and I definitely saw him as the
most survived survivable of the three
major options
hillary-bernie and and and Donald what I
what I felt then at the time and I said
so is that we should not have a choice
between three boomer candidates or older
candidates we need fresh new ideas and
none of these people's experience speaks
at all to me so it's not that I was
wildly supportive of Bernie and his
economics policies which made very
little sense to me it was that he was
struggling to be a decent human being
and he was an absolute maverick like
Trump but he was a maverick who had
managed to survive within the system so
there was a level of trust that I had
with him even though I thought he was
economically confused mm-hmm what what I
believe now is is that we've we've been
shown what got put into that container
called fake news or media manipulation
and rather than it being terrifying I
you know I'm sort of on the fence about
this but I I think I'm gonna go in the
direction of funny like this report that
just came out from Dayton Society yeah
on the alternative influence network had
you ever heard of these people before
this report by the well I'd heard of the
woman who founded it Dana Boyd and I've
actually Co runs sessions with an
adviser of theirs named Hilary Mason who
you know as a top notch data scientist
so I didn't have the most negative
impression of the roster of people
there's some people who I view as very
ideological over over there but I didn't
actually know about data in society it
sort of seemed to be an echo of things
that you see in the Tim O'Reilly Network
or what is it the Berkman Center at
Harvard so it's connected up through all
of the major institutions if you look at
the funders of data in society it's the
sloan Foundation it's the New York Times
it's you know I think it's open society
yeah so Bill and Melinda Gates so what's
going on let's pause for a second for
people that don't know what
this thing is that I think most people
watching probably do but basically they
issued this report the alternative
influencer network and it was sort of
how the reactionary right is monetizing
and extending their influence throughout
YouTube and it was heavily based on me
as one of the people I think I was
mentioned seventy seven times in this
report Joe Rogan of course was included
Jordan Peterson was included Tim Poole
who I've had on the show Dennis Prager
Prager was interesting that he was
included because they included his name
Dennis Prager even though this was about
youtubers but really they were going
after his channel Prager you I think
that's just an interesting distinction
that they went after the man not the
Channel then there was a series of other
people on there that I have no idea who
they are there were real white
nationalists I suppose on there from
what I understand one and but basically
they issued this insane graph linking us
all together that looked like a cap is
six degrees of Kevin Bacon on steroids
and there were there are errors I mean I
know there's errors even related to me
they didn't have me and Rogan connected
three times I mean you ruin the whole
okay go ahead wait everything that's
wrong okay please you know there's a lot
to say about I know well but the thing
is is that at first I thought it was
like the 80s and I forgotten that we had
these channels yeah you know greens
company was on there you couldn't leave
it well the the funny thing is is that
before there was no way to fight these
things like if you couldn't jack into
the network of newspapers and radio
stations there was no way to fight back
so all of these things were terrifying
but I noticed that I wasn't a part of
this graph and at first I had this like
sense of relief and then I thought well
I should just go on Dave Rubin show and
become part of the alternative
reactionary influence network as a
Bernie voter because this is gay
pro-choice pot-smoking against the death
penalty over there big right winger
right you know I mean as a fellow by the
way just as a fellow neo-nazi can I ask
how you spent Young Kippur oh it's
lovely I broke it with bagels yeah
exactly I mean they've got Ben Shapiro
on there saying
either way it's so completely insane
yeah and that it it it really doesn't
require refutation what it requires as a
middle schooler with an IQ of above
eighty and an assignment to say what's
wrong with the methodology of this
report because so far as I could tell
there is no methodology in the report
it's not just that it's got errors and
what's can you explain what in a report
like this what a proper methodology
would be because from what I could
understand in the 61 pages of this thing
they basically just tried to link us
together this person talked to this
person this person once interviewed this
person this person appeared somewhere
with this person for getting the error
is in those connections but that to me
doesn't strike me as a methodology it
strikes me as just it's just human
connections people cross peope with
people doesn't mean you're promoting
them it doesn't mean you're secretly
working with anywhere that you're in in
a network I mean that's what they were
really going for here and I think
there's a bigger reason for that that
we're gonna get doing a little bit well
okay so what could they have done yeah
if you were if you were doing it
properly right and you were trying to
show here's a small group of people that
have created this network to extend
these horrible ideas or alternative we
do have influence and there is a part of
us that is a network so in fact that's
not really where the problem right what
you would do normally is you would set
out some list of qualities
characteristics that didn't pick names
that you selectively wanted to feature
mm-hmm and you would say okay here's
what we did we we came up with the
following rule
somebody needs to appear on at least
three shows we've done this so that it's
exhaustive and and everybody who fits
these criteria is listed on this graph
and look what emerges or they at least
hold certain beliefs right could you do
it that way or is that straight so
you're asking me what just what I would
think would be a proper method okay so
you'd state something that was fairly
neutral that didn't name anyone and then
it would emerge that the network was the
solution to the
carefully stated problem and then you'd
say isn't this interesting that when I
looked for that those criteria it picks
out Dave Rubin and Richard Spencer and
it doesn't pick out
Ezra Klein and Sara John mm-hmm
unfortunately you know Ezra Klein does a
podcast with Sam Harris Sam Harris is
named in the appendix but he's not on
the graph I think yeah the you know Noam
Chomsky has appeared on stefan molyneux
so if you actually put all of the people
who would occur as part of a proper
method of methodological discovery of a
network there would be things that
didn't go your way and then there'd be a
section at the end that says we know
that the following anomalies are present
people who are clearly opposed to you
know you might have Linda Sarsour with a
note on the network right and you'd say
okay why is Linda Sarsour to two degrees
separated from Richard Spencer right and
then you'd have to say look these are
maybe some deficiencies maybe you know
here's some here's some ideas for
further research but the point is that
there was nothing like a methodology and
when you look at the author's
ideological commitments which she's very
comfortable sharing they fly in the face
of facts so that there's no she's not
trying to present herself so far as I
can tell as a dispassionate researcher
she's trying to present herself as an
activist she has tweets from August
since deleted because she uses that
tweet scrubber thing or whatever it is
talking about howdy platforming people
is the answer to these problems that she
proposes we have but pretty clear let's
go down there Dave I could understand
somebody saying look let's talk about
what deep platforming is and let's talk
about it in neutral terms so that it
it's not being used selectively to wipe
out reasonable ideas that I disagree
with there's no pretense there's no
semblance and that's why I think this is
that I have a different feeling about
this than I had expected which is
bringing this on give me more yeah cuz
if you show me who's willing to salute
this report you know is this going to be
featured by the Berkman Center at
Harvard yeah I went to Harvard you
couldn't turn something like this in
yeah into a Statistics Department or a
math department and be considered a
researcher you'd be considered a lunatic
and so if Harvard then salutes this
thing that's going to tell us I'm not an
ideological commitment does the New York
Times support this they're certainly
funding this they're finding the Center
for data in society so we know that the
Guardian liked it we know that Vox liked
it by BuzzFeed Wired I didn't see
BuzzFeed actually yeah BuzzFeed it I saw
New York I saw New York Times reporters
tweeting at NBC News reporters tweeting
it but but did it did it did it occur in
the New York Times because I'm seeing no
they so I haven't seen that I'm seeing
that even the publication's who probably
would like to find that this report is
reasonable no they got to be very
careful because if you embrace this
report you're telling it's so bad that
you're telling people what your
standards are for intellectual discourse
mm-hmm and that's what makes it
fascinating so so you want more of this
because you believe this will hasten the
destruction of the monster we've been
fighting basically I want to know how I
can help them to produce more reports
like this yeah you have to understand
what the purpose of a report like this
is and I think somewhere this is my
fifth appearance on your show sorry I'm
probably winning some whisky for the Q&A
how about that all right the I brought
up this gated institutional narrative
and this is where this report is
supposed to slot in in other words it's
not meant for individual consumption
it's meant to be a sizable report and so
it's got like high production graphics
and hey it's a PDF PDFs are hard to make
like it's not a word I'm glad you fix
the PDF it's logged in so the idea is
you're supposed to be able to hold a
conference let's say under the auspices
of the National Academy of Sciences or
Brookings or Berkman Center or whatever
it is and you're supposed to say well
earlier in the year we have this
fabulous report by Rebecca Lewis at the
Center for data and society and and and
they're doing some remarkable work about
how people are being radicalized and I
think this is very important impressive
and and so you have a big serious
conversation in a closed conference and
the release proceedings and then maybe
you'll allow the public in for the for
the final day and you say well thank you
all for joining the conversation of
course none of those people in the
audience has allowed the conversation
right and that's what the gated
institutional narrative is all about
that if you don't own a seat somewhere
on the institutional network you can't
get into that conversation so you
there's nobody who's going to be in a
position to say you realize that report
would not be acceptable at any
reasonable middle school as a as a data
project so that's what they're some
someone was hoping for this but I think
even for these institutions they're
going to be a little bit wary because
it's so naked Lee ideological and so
piss-poor on on the analytics okay so
when I saw this thing come out and I
called you and I was pissed and I was
like ah here we go again just another
one of these things and I was saying you
know this is just their way of inching
us closer to D platforming it maybe you
think but you think that's a secondary
issue here well one friend says and by
the way thank you for having my friend
Peter teal on oh yeah no problem that
was great yeah we can talk about that um
you know Peter has this this brilliant
way of analyzing things is that you have
something that a powerful entity could
do and then he says but the level of
violence needed to accomplish that goal
is probably not
something that that entity could stomach
well I have no doubt that people are
fantasizing about doing to all of these
people what was done to Alex Jones right
with Alex Jones there's so much
over-the-top stuff that a lot of people
who breathed a sigh of relief thank God
somebody rid us of that terrible Alex
Jones I'm not gonna get into whether
Alex Jones is good or bad
no no but putting putting a limit on
continuously they could try to take the
alternative influence network that they
have identified off the air okay what
would that look like
you've gotta somehow get rid of Joe
Rogan Jordan Peters Ben Shapiro Dave
Rubin Sam Harris etc etc and we've got
new kids coming up all the time who are
said to be major voices so are you gonna
get rid of all of these people because
if you do that the only way to do that
is in such a visible way the the way
they can do with this now is is
harassment through algorithms where
suddenly you don't get the number of
views that fit the pattern your
demonetized you can't make money you
know that maybe there's a glitch and
you're thrown off the platform and then
they say sorry sorry sorry
etc etc this is just like this that
they're harassing us it's digital
harassment so do you think that we know
this IDW crew whoever this is at this
point do you think we kind of dropped
the ball on not offering Jones a better
defense not having anything to do with
the content I don't
I've watched maybe 10 minutes of him
ever so put the content aside but that
there was this digital assassination
basically where it's like alright well
if this guy can't be on Twitter and
can't be on PayPal can't be on you to
make it can eat can he have a phone is
he allowed to have a phone of running
water at his house I mean what what is
though are the publicans be allowed to
use streets that's a good question that
is a good question where are we going
with it
I don't know so should we have offered
not because we were defending him or any
of his ideas but should we have offered
man these platforms doing this basically
in conjunction with each other because
it all happened you know
within a 24 hour yeah I thought about
this I mean I alright tweeted about it
and I said something about this is
ominous having nothing to do with Jones
that all of these platforms D platform
him D platform Tim sudden suddenly yeah
but my belief about this is that because
the platforms occupy a very strange
position I don't think we have good
jurisprudence around these platforms so
we clearly know it bothers me that we
don't realize that the the shift has
been so dramatic are these companies are
they utilities are they natural
monopolies because of the QWERTY problem
of path dependence I'm not positive that
we have the economic theory the legal
jurisprudence to just refer to
precedents and say well this is a clear
violation of the Sherman and Clayton
Acts or that you know this is covered
under New York Times V Sullivan or who
knows what I think we're gonna need a
lot of new thinking and so the problem
that I'm having is I don't know exactly
where to fight this and fighting it
around Alex Jones particularly with the
Sandy Hook mm issue strikes me as I want
to be maximally effective so I said I
was very clear about taking issue with
the sudden D platforming but you know to
the point where you're saying that
businesses should be allowed to do what
they want to do well is this is this
simply a business and yeah we you know
keep in mind that we have very good
information about how our government
used to harass people who held dissident
political perspectives in the 50s 60s
and 70s but we've got no information
about whether or not this is being
coordinated through the intelligence
communities we don't know I have to talk
to before about Tim and sometimes people
call it time for technology intelligence
media and if you add education that is
the universities and the research
infrastructure that conglomerate that
that Association of major institutions
we don't know what we're up against so
how do we start thinking about this
issue I actually think that this issue
that you've just laid out here not just
because it affects us in a very obvious
way now we're doing this I actually
believe this is
probably a far bigger issue than
anything going on with Cavanaugh right
now or certainly the other ridiculous
political machinations or half the stuff
going on in terms this way that we
conduct and transfer information and who
in a sense and who you can get it and
yeah well since making comes on the back
of our ability to communicate with each
other and I think this is probably the
biggest issue out there and by the way
I'm glad you just called me out on it
but this is where I'm running my
classical liberal part that veers into
libertarianism is starting where the
rubbers meeting the road number and
maybe there isn't I don't want the
government to come in you know that's
against everything I stand no it's not
against everything you stand for look
one of my goals is to get you off of
telling I'm hardcore libertarianism I
think competition is still the answer
but I do think they agree that where
competition works does the answer but if
you are truly free market ear you should
know about market failure yeah and you
should not pretend that markets can
solve all problems because you will have
a world that is absolutely red of tooth
and claw well I think we're sort of
heading there with this I understand
that I want to create a YouTube but I'm
trying to say that you know all I'm
asking is that you reconsider your
position because of the complexities
about you know a path dependent monopoly
which we refer to sometimes as QWERTY
mm-hmm
after the typewriter may have a funny
structure and it's not clear that we
should break it up or not break it up or
regulate it or not regulate it these are
open questions and I'm absolutely I
agree with you as somebody who's much
more in a classic progressive position
although it has nothing to do with what
people you claim is your aggressive ism
now right that where the market works
you let the market work yeah right but
it's not clear that the market is meant
to work here because there's too many
asymmetries of information I mean Google
holds so many of our secrets yeah and so
what happens when they've got a problem
and they can also read all your email
and then you're thinking like okay well
that's a level of power that's not like
a company you know maybe somebody can
invent some some sort of email where the
company can't read your email but then
the question is are they responsible for
regulating right
some of that yeah okay but that's
exactly what the data and society people
are supposed to be doing or the the
Berkman Center the problem is is that we
have a situation in which it's as if the
grown-ups whoever they are held a
conference which we were not invited to
they made a whole bunch of findings you
know that that these people are extreme
these people are good if you think about
it in in terms of like the Hulk the Hulk
you know often talks in sentences that
don't have one part of speech you know
so the Harvard good then it's strong
yeah
well somehow they have an idea that
Harvard has our best interests in mind
that more or less the Democratic Party
is that which has to defeat Trump and
the progressive agenda and I put huge
scare quotes around progressive here
because it's anything but yeah that
those forces the grown-ups as they see
themselves need to take this thing back
and my point to them is are you aware of
who you have in this alternative
influence network because I think you're
sadly mistaken if you don't imagine that
the firepower outside of the
institutional network intellectual
firepower is as great or greater than
the intellectual firepower inside of the
institutions which are constantly
requiring people to say absolutely
outrageous ridiculous false things and
so good people tend to eventually get so
fed up that they can't stay inside of
the institutions and the magic of this
alternative Network and I mean that in
the good sense yeah is that it's based
around individuals the main war is not
left versus right at the moment mm-hmm
it's institutions versus things that are
much closer to being it's individuals so
the Rubin report isn't just you but it's
a team that is relatively small and
these relatively small teams don't take
on these terrible characteristics at the
large and
institutions and so the reason that
we're able to be so effective in my
opinion is that all of the institutions
are fighting certain problems having to
do with we don't have a a really
dependable source of growth we don't
have a great national story they're all
sputtering they're all struggling and
the individuals are where the vitality
and the energy is so if Jordan Peterson
has given us a biblical lecture on this
right now I think he'd be talking about
David versus Goliath and in this case it
might be Dave versus Google but but
right I mean that's the idea that the
small operation the individual or can be
just a small set of individuals we have
a lot of leverage because we don't have
this cumbersome cumbersome machine
around us and we don't you know I have
to answer to myself and a couple other
people that I hold in close confidence
but that's it and that that's nimble and
that's great
yeah so that's powerful that's powerful
even though it feels kind of scary well
but what are you riding on you're right
people I think know you're riding on
internals pipes stories oh you meant you
meant literally yeah right we are still
using their stuff we're still using
their stuff and if you take this idea
you see the deep platforming movement is
quite clever because free speech is
enshrined in the Constitution so they
can't really go around you know it's
like it's like somebody's saying you're
entitled to play your guitar your
electric guitar but we have the right to
cut off your power well you can barely
hear an electric guitar without an amp
right and so the platforming is they
it's a failover into the next level of
where can we take this fight mm-hmm and
I think it's very important that people
read a I think it's a transcript of a
speech by the founder of data and
society Institute or Center Dana Boyd
where she talks about two important
concepts one of one of in a speech one
of which is data voids and a data void
is someplace where people want to search
for something but there's not a lot of
information
and that's fascinating because that's a
lot of how the mainstream institutions
control us so I have a very clean
example of this the idea that you can be
a immigration restriction aesthetically
r--'s NFI like everything throughout
your life speaks to your interest in
foreign cultures and your openness to
other people but you happen to be a
restriction Asst there is a complete
void if you go search zina file
restriction estaba blind me at the top
because what may be a majority position
in the United States is acknowledged at
nowhere meaning that you might be into
other cultures you might even be married
to an Indian woman you might love all
sorts of things speak a gajillion
languages every time I get in a car with
you you're speaking another language you
might care about all these other
cultures for a million other reasons but
it doesn't mean you want open borders
well it is what most people think I
think well it's very confusing with an
analogy would be do you wish to adopt
every person you have over for dinner
the idea of being open to dinner guests
and expecting that as much as you love
them they will probably leave if not
after dinner then after a few days or a
few weeks you kicked me out but I was
drunk beer UNK
all right focus sorry so we have a
situation in which these data voids are
real and they're created by the
unwillingness to report now this is
what's radicalizing people so that's
what that was one of the four types of
fake news you originally discussed right
well avoidance of an important topic is
actually a type well if I can remember
yeah let's see if you can do it alright
so there was algorithmic there was
institutional I mean give me an example
of each one as you okay also very
algorithmic fake news has to do with
there's something important but you
can't find it via via search and it's
it's down ranked so that it's it's
effectively suppressed and something
else is accentuated there was
institutional where any institution that
wants
can broadcast information and people
treat it as if it's news but individuals
cannot do this then there was narrative
fake news where the New York Times is
the principal offender here which that
they figure out the narrator the
narrative arc ahead of time and we we
don't know why they would do that
because the the facts haven't come in
but they have an idea of how the facts
should be organized as they come in
mm-hmm and then there's just false news
yeah
so these but wasn't one of them oh so
the first one is where you're like where
the always maker the closest got it but
sometimes that occurs just naturally
like what if nobody thought wire why
don't we have articles on Xena file
restriction lists oh we just forgot we
forgot about what may be a majority
position in the United States but it's
like it's so large that it's pretending
that you can't find an aircraft carrier
in a community Harbor yeah so that's
what makes people crazy so the the big
data voids if you will are people who
believe that let's say that trade is
generally good but that it isn't a
rising tide that raises all ships and
that you have to do work around it to
make sure you don't decimate communities
and States mm-hmm you know there was
very little real work done on what what
the effects of trade would be
immigration we just mentioned and then
there's the the I believe that there's a
linkage between terror and Islam but I'm
I would think is Lama philic because I'm
fascinated by the culture religion and
find it very easy to to you know
socialize in that portion of the world
because it's it's very similar to many
of the values that I hold we just had a
great night with your what best friend
from college who happens to be Muslim
like who even noticed yeah it doesn't
matter right so the by creating these
voids saying don't mention the following
obvious fact because if you do we have
an interpretation if you disagree with
us on policy we can infer that you're a
bad person
we a moral failing will have to be
affixed to your name
perpetuity that thing is making people
absolutely hate these institutions and
my goal in trying to unelect Donald
Trump is to say there is no reason that
Donald Trump should be running the table
by monopolizing these data voids yes you
can believe that there's a link between
terror and Islam and not be Islamophobic
yes you can believe that we have a
problem with the way in which we
negotiate trade agreements and you can
still want to be open to the world and
not a protectionist at heart yes you can
be a restriction estándares n a file
simultaneously though those are my big
three examples of what makes people hate
the institutions and in some sense I've
been thinking that Donald Trump is like
a company fragging its senior offices
like we don't want to be led by people
who tell us that we're deplorable
because if you pee on our leg and tell
us it's raining we say no you're peeing
on my leg please stop right and those
people who want to say look we are the
natural guardians of America we know who
needs to be de platformed we know who
shouldn't have access to PayPal we
should be able to write our Terms of
Service in such a way that pure virtue
is boosted and not niceness is pushed
down and by the way pure virtue is
everybody I like or nobody I don't right
right right
okay well none of us want to be governed
by this nobody who loves Liberty and
loves this particular country and loves
the Enlightenment wants to be governed
by this and so this is an unwanted
institutional class and we're trying to
throw them off what happened was it was
so uniform throughout the institutions
that they couldn't field candidates that
spoke to this fed up Ness I mean we're
just fed up who are who are these baby
boomers who are entitled to tell us how
to think and I'm saying this is somebody
who comes you know from from the left it
shouldn't be a left-right distinction
yeah more or less people who have
interesting perspectives as individuals
are looking at this and say we know
you're trying to get us off the
platforms we know
Engineers hate us are you reading our
DMS are you going through our emails
what are you doing over there and that's
where this the alex jones incident the
changes in the Terms of Service so now
like you can be thrown off of a platform
even if you conduct yourself properly on
platform because of your off platform
behavior yeah a lot of people probably
don't know about that you are not making
that out but this is this is what
happened when I came on your show and I
said I said the fake news story is
inauthentic what I was doing was I was
putting a marker and I was saying watch
this space because what they're gonna do
is they're gonna fill it with some kind
of machinery and so there's been a lot
of changes one there are all of these
reporting mechanisms
you've got loud groups who objects to
things you put them on it a truth in
safety council and then the idea is that
all of the squeaky wheels who are upset
with things if you give them free pizza
and you give them a place at the table
they may shut up but they're also doing
this free work with it probably often
doesn't need to be done I'm not saying
that there isn't abuse on these systems
but you want the abuse to be even-handed
if you have a hashtag like Ezra Klein
brought up kill all men mm-hmm why is
kill all men did you read this article
in beautiful I'm not a huge fan of his
frankly well are see in the last couple
days I find him quite personable he's
been very nice I'm putting him on a list
he's had dinner at your house I've had
dinner a year but but he's also been
said I know it he's also been savaged so
I'm better I'm trying to understand the
perspective yeah all right so I'm trying
to figure out is the nice intelligent
guy who came over for Shabbat dinner the
same guy is the guy who's rationalizing
kill all men I didn't actually mind his
rationalization of kill all men what he
said is is that within a small group of
feminists Twitter which I don't think
really exists people talk like that but
since it's an open platform it doesn't
have any walls around there
he said that inside that community that
phrase meant it would be nice if the
world were slightly better for women so
take that @ take him at his word you
would imagine that that same community
if it was epistemic ly consistent would
also believe hey we can't police
microaggressions because we have to
figure out whether those things are
actually not as toxic as they sound
mm-hmm but that this is what's
fascinating is we think that the same
community that should object to anything
like you know referring to mankind as
bigotry yeah that community should also
be allowed to use the hashtag kill all
men now that doesn't make any sense I'm
very focused on are you granting
yourself a privilege that you will grant
to no one else
because if you recall but created the
Reformation it was the selling of
indulgences and I believe that what the
left thinks it has is an indulgence
system that is Sara John when promoted
to the Editorial Board of the New York
Times should be granted an indulgence
because she's actually a great person
and she engaged in some bad tweet eree
and we should be there should be
compassion there should be forgiveness
there should not be a black mark on the
record so basically she believes in all
the right things according to the New
York Times she can say whatever she
wants about white journal but she
believes in prove you know she's a
progressive and blah blah blah but this
other guy who once said something which
was ambiguous should be be platform for
life yeah and I don't think without
profanity I don't think I have any way
of communicating how hateful that is how
dare you literally how dare you suggest
that some community is entitled to own
both of these things ultimate
forgiveness for their members and the
right to police everyone else and that's
what we have to fight so what do you
make of what I would argue is the lack
of clear thinking on behalf of these
people I don't want to make it about
Ezzor it doesn't matter but like look a
report like this comes out and if we
were to parse I honestly I didn't know
at least ten of the people I've never
even heard of them a whole bunch of them
I've had muted on Twitter because they
don't like me so it's like the idea that
we were all connected is just silly but
if they had done a report just on true
white nationalists right you know they
actually probably could have got some
on our side maybe not to have them deep
platform because that's not where where
I would want to go with it but that
there's this group of people doing some
really bad stuff here's what it is but
but they do a sloppy version yeah
out-and-out racists there's an
oppression they need they need a certain
amount look there is still structural
oppression in the world I don't want to
have to argue that I can I can make a
convincing case so I do believe that
there is structural oppression in our
society the problem instructed what do
you mean by structural because this will
be a big hang-up point for a lot of
people well that you know you you don't
have anything that is explicitly against
one race but when you have a decision
about where a road has to be placed in
the level of disruption or how schools
are paid from property taxes that are
local you have self-perpetuating systems
where the the rich become more
advantaged and the poor become more
disadvantaged over time that wasn't
nurse' a racial though that was rich
versus poor well but the point is that
what if that correlates and you know
there might be rich versus poor there
might be male versus female I don't
think it's the case that we've gotten
rid of all oppression mmm and I just
think that that would be silly to
suggest and it's not it's important that
we not lose sight that because our
progressives at the moment are terrible
that we couldn't steal man that point if
that was in our interest and my
intention is to do so that said there
isn't enough oppression to explain all
of the phenomena that we're seeing so I
go to the very simple example of top
hundred chess players one of them is
female now that cannot be in my
estimation likely caused by the LA yeah
it is oppression encoded into the rules
of chess is it because you know chess is
is sort of cryptically male and that if
we if we did it with Barbie dolls or or
some other you know body-positive female
thing that girls would suddenly become
50/50 I don't know I think it's unlikely
to imagine that I don't think that it
would have to be one versus ninety-nine
and maybe it's 20 versus 80 or 40 versus
60 who knows but it's unlikely that it's
a hundred percent structural oppression
like one of my jokes is in depression
and online anonymous chest it's all that
well so you have a situation where my my
team guessed wrong we thought if we
could get rid of redlining if we could
get rid of literacy tests if we could
get rid of all of the things that were
holding people back that were just naked
ly ridiculous that we would have this
much more even society and while there's
still more work to be done I would say
that preliminary indications are is that
that solves some of the problem but it
didn't solve as much of the problem as
we were hoping so now you have two very
difficult choices do you decide that
really the problem is is that the
oppression is super cryptic and it's
much you know it's it's much worse than
anyone imagines that's why you're
policing microaggressions or do you
decide huh I wonder if there are other
factors and that's kind of disturbing
and I'm scared to even consider that
question and that's that's the choice
that that the progressives and the
lefties have have faced and can I take
it to a slightly less heady place
perhaps which is I I get you on that on
the intellectual level but I think
there's just a lazy
it's just lazy thinking for young people
it's just lazy to think the system's
rigged against you it's just lazy to
think they're coming after you because
of your gender or your sexuality or your
color or most of their aiming a few
souls of your age but it's but it's
empower in other words it's empowering
yeah to these people to think the whole
system's against me I'm gonna destroy it
so it's like it's just an easy answer as
opposed to nobody to clean up your room
and get your [ __ ] together yeah well
when we had that I that was tremendous
fun having Jordan and Ben on the show
yeah and did that but I pushed back on
that which is no there really is an
issue particularly intergenerationally a
lot of these people if I take the
standard child rearing house where
somebody you know at age 26 wants to
propose to somebody at age 24 and say
hey you know I've got enough means to
have a house and we can have a few kids
and you can take off work
for a few years to raise them when kids
are the most demanding that's very hard
to do at the moment the the labor market
needs to get much tighter we need to
have employers writhing in pain before
that becomes possible again and I
support making the labor market tighter
in order to redistribute some of the
wealth using market mechanisms to people
who need to start their lives and to
become homeowners and to have a stake in
the system and we made a huge mistake in
my opinion not understanding that when
it's so difficult to start a life in
your 20s that feels adult that those
people are now pissed yeah and
rightfully so
because we're not really hearing them so
I think that often though the one that
is most important to me is that we
missed the boat on intergenerational
oppression I think that one really feels
salient now there are other things
having to do with with race and gender
which we have to get to and I'm not
going to pretend that I don't think that
there are problems in those area they're
very much very very clearly are but
there isn't enough problem at the moment
I mean we have so many opportunities
where the world crying out for diversity
that you know we have to we have to be
looking how much of this is solvable by
going after oppression and how much are
we having to event invent oppressions in
order to avoid looking at more
disturbing questions and I think that
what's going on is that the our betters
in the institutional world have already
decided that anyone searching for
explanations that are not oppression
based and things that can't be cured
with diversity is a bad person and
that's what's so disturbing
let me ask saying just on a kind of
personal note that we've talked a little
bit about privately that as a guy that
came from the institutions that has
plenty of friends and colleagues in the
institutions I mean you talk about all
this stuff and it's in a certain way
there's
level of kind of kissing that goodbye
right I mean at some level by being here
and calling these things out constantly
and I liken that to I I forward you
emails probably every day well from
people from a zillion walks of life sure
I mean you know high school teachers to
choreographers to lighting people to all
scared scared of the exact same thing
that you're describing they are seeing
this faux diversity come down on them
and certain people now by their gender
usually male by their skin color usually
white and all of these other things are
realizing their careers are coming to an
end that they are afraid that their
future no longer works the things that
they believed in no longer worked so
first I just want to know just you
personally like it's it that isn't real
shift for you it has to be right I don't
even know if you want to do this
publicly but I mean let me see if I even
understand we are let's talk about what
it is that we learn when we do shows and
we meet people afterwards here's what we
know that nobody else in my opinion
knows we know that people are terrified
yeah the people who are coming to these
shows are saying thank you for speaking
out I'm almost ready to say something at
work but I fear that I'll lose my job
and my livelihood and I've got two kids
at home and by the way it's often things
like I believe in low taxes it's not you
know - my god it's yeah it's nothing I
believe in free speech yeah I think
maybe James do more was yeah it was
railroaded yeah oh my god but he's James
to Morrie's that he's that tech broke
okay that's that's a row on the end of
anything but also the idea to route the
bro report right it's like okay now we
don't have to take it seriously but also
him as tech bro him prying that he's
like this frat boy like like cocky
[ __ ] this is the most de mujer award
yeah this is the most no he's like yeah
I think he's openly on the spectrum
right he's a he's a total he's the
shyest I mean really in all the shows
I've done I don't know how
how many hundreds of interviews and he's
the only guest that I felt I needed to
spend probably a half hour in the
greenroom just chatting with him to get
comfortable enough to talk this was not
a bro who wants to get in there and bro
it up this is the fun part yeah like I
think Bernie brothers were totally you
know it was basically an invention the
that institutional voice is dying
because it's so funny
and I think that this because it's so
ludicrous at this bullet the things you
and I happen to have really good
information about how many people are
scared and we also know that the reason
that they're scared is that a tiny
number of people who hold these very
extreme positions have found their way
into the high leverage seats if you're
sitting on the Editorial Board of the
New York Times that's a high leverage
seat or if you're a columnist that's a
high leverage seat or if you're in the
admissions office or if you're in human
resources or if you are you know a judge
or a law maker and so people are seeking
out these high leverage positions if
they hold very radical perspectives
which has to do with alternative logic I
mean I think I want to say very clearly
that the real reason that I'm so dead
set against this is that people can't be
trusted with this level of epistemic
inconsistency and I've referred to this
as the alternative logic Network and I
just want to say one or two things from
a mathematicians perspective you asked
me like how I see this from a map yeah
give me a little math for God's sake all
right there's a principle called the
principle of explosion and it it says
roughly that from a contradiction you
can deduce anything smuggle one
contradiction through airport security
and on the other side you can come up
with anything 2 equals 7/2 equals a
chicken you know the United States
doesn't exist and so this is where
scientists get very persnickety about
somebody saying oh come on just ol let
us tweak what we say about biology a
little
it's like no there will be no tweaking
of logic itself we are not going to
allow you if we can avoid it to smuggle
one structural contradiction in because
once you get one in it's all over this
is this has to do with the unity of
nature
I don't want biology to give me many of
the results that it gives me tough
biology is what it is I don't have the
right to say you know let's say
microcephaly small heads has no effect
on intelligence or that people with Down
syndrome are just as capable as anybody
else because it's not true I want it to
be true but am i wanting it to be true
doesn't have that effect and if I start
making those adulterations then the
whole thing falls apart so this is sort
of where you and your brother Bret and
and your sister-in-law Heather and many
other pejorative and a bunch of other
people have been saying that that's the
fear that if the Gender Studies stuff
and all of this progressive then your
Shack gets into science yeah we we
literally blow apart all the progress
all the real progress we've ever made
something it can actually make progress
on the male/female stuff if you're
pretending that males and females are
both simultaneously totally different
and totally the same yeah right and you
have to pretend both in order to get
this new version of progressivism to
work so you're literally smuggling in a
contradiction so if you say look we
really need a diverse workplace let's
say between men and women and we notice
that in this particular occupation it's
80/20 and that it has to do only with
oppression because otherwise it would be
50/50 well what you've just done is
you've said we know that there's no
cognitive difference between males and
females because we've just assigned all
of the difference to oppression right
because it would be exactly equal but if
you allow males and females to to
co-exist you're gonna get this huge
bonanza because now you're gonna have
intellectual diversity now there is
actually something very clever and very
important to say that has to do with the
kind of Fisher's notion of equivalence
of males and females in terms of fitness
strategies
so there is a kind of equivalence but
when you destroy the true biological
understanding of the why males and
females have the same expected return as
fitness strategies in favor of this
dime-store nonsense you actually destroy
the ability to correct for imbalances
and so we're Brett and Heather and I
come down is that we say in your rush to
build utopia you're gonna destroy
everything that we've done and you can't
take the shortcut that's really what's
important the intellectually these
shortcuts will eventually cause the
system to collapse and so it's not that
we're not sympathetic with the idea that
we'd love to see more more female
programmers but let's figure out and
this is actually what d'amour was
focused on it's like what changes can we
make in order to you know respect the
biology and make this work and so I I
think that that's what's what's so
confusing is is the this push to assign
so much to what is essentially an
intellectual universe of pure
contradiction is what's offending many
people who consider themselves
progressives which is like we I think
absolutely we're in the rut that we
progressives are in the right but you
have to do it honestly you can't just
cheat and pretend things that you wish
to be true and close your eyes and put
your fingers in your ears and say I'm
not gonna listen to data and analysis
but do you see any people on the left
besides you guys trying to fix this
thing well this yes
but but they're scared you see this is
what's so terrifying about these current
fake progressives this is that they're
just scary people they they say oh we
need more empathy and then what did what
are they interested in are they
interested in the notion of progress or
justice well justice is all about
sticking it to somebody like you have
something that belongs to this other
person but progress is just like let's
make things better and hopefully you
know where there is injustice we can we
can
identify a bad guy but where there's no
injustice and it's just somebody's out
of luck you're just trying to train to
raise people up I want to say one other
thing that I realized I forgot to say
somewhere else yeah Dana Boyd brought up
a very interesting issue which she
called strategic silence yeah yeah and
the idea which isn't a bad one initially
is that if somebody should not have
their voice amplified let's imagine that
you have a manifesto and you decide that
you're gonna kill 30 people and in the
desire to figure out what the motivation
is that you're gonna have your manifesto
broadcast all over the world so the
Unabomber didn't kill 30 but he killed a
bunch killed a few people and maimed
some people and his manifesto was read
widely so strategic silence is the idea
that reporters should not be played or
used and they should be silent about
certain things I think that what she did
not realize is that this much strategic
silence cannot function in an
intelligent open society people are
simply to mute in the press about all
sorts of things that the rest of us have
a very legitimate interest in knowing
and if you're going to be strategically
silent you should be sharing the idea
that the policy of this paper is that it
doesn't look at motive on individual
instances unless that constitutes a
pattern but like if you take terrorists
killings when somebody reports you know
ten people were killed today and the
attacker said something religious in a
foreign language at the end you're not
helping things you're creating a belief
that there is some kind of conspiracy
and we don't know what that's about is
it an honest desire to protect our
vulnerable communities in which case
many of us would be supportive or is it
because the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia has
some relationship with our government
that may be strategic that we will want
more information about is that is that a
special favor to a foreign power I don't
know what that is
but what I do know is is that if people
are dying and that there's a motive
that's linking multiple killings for
example you can't afford strategic
silence and pretend that this thing just
doesn't exist I think that that's
partially where this our overlords in
the institutional class are so far off
is it that they're not realizing that
there's no possible way to get a rid to
get away with this level of strategic
silence and that's what created Donald
Trump is that he was willing to break
strategic silence everywhere and people
were willing to say look he may be crazy
he may be immoral but at least he's not
under the thumb of whatever this thing
is right but they are crazy and immoral
he's just showing us his crazy in a
moral I think that I think that's the
way the average Trump voter felt their
crazy and immoral these people I thought
UMP is probably crazy immoral but he's
doing it okay I just don't like being
lied to in terms that a stupid child
would never accept because these lies I
need better lives no I do this is what I
talk about adult level fiction are you
talking about the lives of the net' of
the gate institutions or YouTube eyes of
Trump no the gated institution air ative
I understand that you want to not create
an incentive structure so that people
murder people so that they can get their
message out and amplify that makes good
sense to me and when we get to the point
where this thing is big enough we may
have to consider all of the issues that
the traditional media had to consider
mm-hmm however what is absolutely not
acceptable is nobody from the State
Department has ever contacted any one of
us and said hey I'm a little bit worried
as to what you guys are doing do you
understand how this fits in can you come
in you know we understand that you guys
are trying to do good but let us tell
you what u.s. objectives are I've never
been a part of any conversation like
this in the last 20 years right Vox a
lot of BuzzFeed thinks we're so
dangerous and yet nobody's getting
radicalized in the name of Eric
Weinstein well but you know we're also
deriding most of us most of us are
patriotic and I will definitely tailor
some of what I say to national interests
if I'm aware of
those national interests are but if
you're not contacting us and then you're
smearing us and that's your only means
of control I you're not talking about a
free society you're talking about a
Potemkin democracy and I'm not going to
participate your Potemkin democracy you
either have the conversation or be
prepared that nobody's going to obey
your strategic silence and you can get
rid of all of us but you're not going to
get rid of the number of people are
going to take our seats and the more
force you use to get rid of us the more
you're going to radicalize people in the
name of Liberty and I think that you
know this is very important that this is
really a war over since making and we
have a right to be I mean I want to I
want to state this rather emphatically
this idea of deep platforming sensible
rational people who are smarter than the
people who are being platformed who are
more moral more decent and saying well
you can't come in because you're not
part of the narrative agreement that's
how you get something like the French
Revolution and so if you want it if you
want to say thank you to things like the
Rubin report we are taking this the
pressure off of this system you are
lying so transparently about so many
things that no sane or smart person as
an adult can believe and thank God
there's some place where people can come
and say I thought I was losing my mind
and then here you guys are and it's
clear that you're not radical you're not
mean-spirited you're not bit that that
hearted there's no shortage of PhDs in
our system there's no shortage you know
comedians as an alternate intellectual
universe you guys lost the plot in the
institutional space why don't you come
out to the comedy store why don't you
come out out for dinner you know the
next time we have it why don't you call
us into Washington and say look here's
what our strategic objectives are and
we'll say okay you can't lie that much
to people but what you can do is you can
present the truth in different ways and
stop making everyone feel like they're
being gas-lit all right so here's what I
do I think we've done probably about an
hour or so right now maybe an hour ten
we're gonna do about an hour and a half
total just the two of us then we want
you guys in on
this so patreon.com slash rubin report
and whatever level you're at we're gonna
take your questions so jump in on that
all this being said do you think perhaps
that were winning and i say winning i've
been floating this idea for a couple
months now and it's partly because of
what i'm seeing out there with Jordan
and when I've been saying it to the
audience is I always say it with the
kind of tongue-in-cheek you know I think
maybe we're starting to win guys and
3,000 people cheer at once because they
haven't heard that before they haven't
been around a huge group of people where
they can go these people are all sorts
of different I don't know any of these
people but we're kinda in on this
together now Jordan always brings up the
point often in his talks that it's not
about winning per se because if this was
a marriage you don't want to beat your
wife in an argument because then you're
just married to a loser you want to get
to a place where you can both maybe have
won and lost maybe you won the argument
but there was a lesson learned that's
the type of winning I'm talking about I
suspect that they now think we are such
a huge threat for all the reasons that
you've just laid out that they're going
after us in in crazy ways that to me
shows we're winning when I saw the
veracity of the the pieces that came out
after this lovely report here I thought
wow we're actually bigger than these
guys now I don't have hundreds of
millions of dollars behind me like Fox
does
I've got patrons super chat money you
know and it's like we're doing what you
referred to before is this sort of slim
thing which is really cool right now and
there's reasons that it's really strong
right now maybe we'll all the ferocity
the the you mean the veracity of the for
us I think I meant the veracity okay
that these are not these are not very
truthful reports well I meant that they
there were so many of them oh okay wait
give me those two definitions there what
did I say it doesn't matter this is why
I shouldn't be interviewing smarter
people no no no maybe I'm getting it
wrong yeah so the but that there's
there's a signal being read by these
people like holy cow they've got all
this money they've got all the power
yeah I've been tricked my rule in
general I need a dictionary what am i
with with the intelligence community
so whenever you're talking about
something sensitive you should clump
around because yet they don't like to be
surprised this is when I'm talking about
immigration and stuff I try to make a
lot of noise yeah I tried to make a lot
of noise this this alternative Network
and the good part of it which is what
I'm focused on I'm not talking about I
don't know whatever Richard Spencer is
saying to Baked Alaska because who gives
a [ __ ] yeah the good part of this
network has been making a ton of noise
hey this is important people are
listening the events you know are large
people are fanatical and they're normal
people we are winning at some level but
we are losing we're not winning quickly
enough and clean enough well that's what
I always say what do I say to you every
week
we're not moving fast enough well okay
but but this thing has its own pace so
somehow when the gated institutional
narrative issues a report that tries to
take you all out next time guys first of
all assign somebody better than Rebecca
yeah she just doesn't have the chops yet
maybe maybe in five years yeah if you're
going to come for us come loaded for
bear and do it intellectually corrected
my concern is is that the next moves are
going to be highly personal like how do
we take out you know you saw this thing
with Rogen talking about white farmers
in Africa you know Rogan says some crazy
stuff on his show I'm not sure whether
what he said was crazy or not cuz I look
at this but I have no doubt that Joe
holds some positions that are they're
off I certainly hold positions that are
often when I find them I try to correct
them but suddenly the litany of people
going after him as if he's a racist
because he even talked about this well
yes and you know Rebecca Lewis is very
adamant that we shouldn't have gotten
angry at Elon Musk for smoking dope on
the show we should have gotten angry
that Elon Musk went on Joe Rogan because
he gave a platform to James Whitmore and
Jordan Patterson I mean doesn't that
tell you everything this kind of bananas
inside of this tiny little bubble stuff
they're gonna get more sophisticated so
just think about it as a video game
we've been playing with like lots of
low-level
orcs on level zero and okay so then
things got ratcheted up this isn't
terribly serious it's gonna get more
serious because as the narrative comes
to understand just how big these
channels are just how influential they
are let me be open about something part
of the theory behind defining the IDW
has to do with my understanding of how
demography works in presidential
elections so one way of winning an
election is that you find a demographic
that nobody knew existed
mm-hmm and then you speak to them and
they're large enough to sway things so
soccer moms and remember soccer moms
yeah okay another one of these things
was Karl Rove's discovery of the exurbs
where you have urban suburban something
and then rural and between some urban
and rural there was this thing that
nobody understood called the Xserve and
so by finding that you could find some
demographic chunk so both parties let me
be very clear about this the IDW nation
is quite large it's people who've had
enough of low-level lies they don't mind
adult level fictions that are in the
best interests of everybody but they
cannot put up with this level of
nonsense coming out of our institutions
and part of what's going on inside the
institutions that the institutions have
a fake public facing front and then an
internal group and this is how that they
handle things so like I think Dani
Rodrik talked about public voice and
seminar voice then as an economist you
can say certain things to your
colleagues but when you're talking to
the public you have to say different
things and unfortunately they don't even
really nearer each other too closely
right and so it's okay to lie to the
public and so when you talk to an
economist and you say well you can't
possibly believe that immigration and
trade are pure positives of course not
well but you just said that or you loud
your colleague to save you state you
know well that's what you have to say in
front of the public because they can't
follow the analytic argument well okay
that's malpractice
that's academic malpractice you're
engaged in academic
practice when you do that whatever you
say that the public has to be a version
of what you're saying in private or
you're engaged in some kind of Potemkin
state craft and if the idea is that we
can't have a country because actually if
you if you took the Constitution
seriously it wouldn't work then we have
to talk about okay well what are we
going to do that would work that that
would actually be viable but right now
what we have is we have a bunch of not
very intelligent adults who are not very
honest who are sitting in the most
important chairs telling us that we're
all idiots and we're all deplorable
across this political spectrum and
that's not going to work and that we are
going to win that battle so for all the
people that at every Q&A that I do
anywhere either with Jordan or at the
stand-up shows that I'm doing or we got
I think basically this question we did a
little IDW is it pretty awesome actually
within a day we set up an IDW there's an
IDW group now which they're springing up
all over the place this one sprung up in
New York City we did a room down on
Bleecker Street 300 people standing room
only we did it for free they you know
whatever we grifters I know such
grifters we did it for free but but
putting that aside the question that
consistently comes up is okay we get all
this people go you know get all the
ideas we're on board we like what you're
doing we want to help we're ready to you
know show our faces and be part of this
whole thing we know there's a
technological answer how is it that you
morons haven't come up with it yet
there's some version of that like all
right you guys the ones
supposed to be doing all right well what
you and I have been talking and working
on this in various ways and let's just
be honest about this we haven't known
when the right time is because the
investment in trying to rebuild the
infrastructure and then there's a
question about how are you going you
know
if on the other side of this thing there
really is a collaboration between
technology intelligence and media it
doesn't make sense to build the system
only to have it torn down by people with
special access in a non-competitive non
market kind of a way but make no mistake
this is a viable concept I think it's
going to happen I think it's important
that it happened before 2020 and the key
you know people should know that there's
a lot
billionaire interest in this there's a
lot and I don't mean one person I mean
several billionaires are sniffing around
this hmm and i think ben shapiro just
got this show on fox i'll be on this
friday okay so this is going to heat up
and i think what's really important is
to watch what happens to data in society
as this particular report finds its
course because if what we see is that
the institutions agree to cite this
because it's a big serious report in a
PDF file then that's gonna tell us a lot
about how far the institutions are gone
and uh you and I differ somewhat where I
believe I want to rebuild the
institutions because I think it's a
shame too we've got some bad hermit
crabs and some perfectly good shells I
don't want to crack the shells just to
get at the hermit crabs I think your
feeling is is that things are so rotten
that it might be better starting from
scratch well I feel that mostly about
the Democrats I don't feel that about
our institutions so I don't feel that
about our academic institutions and
things of that nature I think those
things I agree I want to keep that shell
let's get rid of the the bad crabs that
are in there fine but the Democrats I
think it's basically through and through
at this point but maybe not me and and I
would be believe me if the day comes and
I have to eat crow on that one because
they came back to sanity and there's
suddenly a new JFK and a daniel patrick
moynihan and i will gladly eke row okay
Mia culpa the whole shebang well I think
one of the big questions is how do we
save the you know I think I've I've
asked before does this come down to the
University of Chicago or the only ones
who are holding the line on the
Enlightenment standards but I think one
of the things we should be doing in the
in the academic institutions is having
debates where two departments are
studying the exact same thing like
gender and sex in biology departments
and Gender Women's Studies departments
or for example the wage gap where you
have the economist version of this and
then you have let's say the women is
that is version of this we should be
holding debates
bring about the unity of knowledge and
so we understand where are we divided if
you have two different academic
standards I think people would be
shocked if they looked at the article
which introduced the concept I think of
white privilege and maybe may up which
was like unpacking the knapsack coming
out of Wellesley if they looked at the
that's where a lot of this stuff was
born right that very piece well that
some of it was born in that piece some
of it was born I think it woman's name
is professor Crenshaw at UCLA the
intersectionality which originally had a
very different flavor than what we call
intersectionality today it's very
important to look at the at the the
genesis of these ideas and to look what
is their academic pedigree and you know
they're not all terrible ideas but a lot
of them are just your wrists exciting
things that are much farther down in the
stack mm-hmm and the it's not tamal
anybody you look if if the wage gap is
really 25 cents I want to know but I
don't trust that the wage gap is 25
cents if somebody refuses to control for
things like you know the choice of what
field they get their training or how
much can work they're doing and you know
as I've said on this program before if
the problem is is that too much kin work
is falling to females and that this is
uncompensated we may have to do
something which recognizes this real
labor that is being done for society and
monetary terms women may need to get
paid more mm-hmm you know but let's make
the arguments honestly and let's stop
lying about everything where if you
don't sign up for the idea that there's
a 25 cent wage gap which has no known
source other than oppression that you
need to be deep platformed and not being
able to learn earn a living because your
views are beyond the pale that's that's
that's moronic I think that's a break
right there
that was pretty soon you were something
so finely focused you know I do all
these shows with you and I'm like huh is
what is he saying really I want to get
back to the tits for info magic square
enix large exceptionally groups whatever
the chance I really only did that just
so in the title we could put tits Freud
and darkest hits on YouTube plays we
never saw what happened with that
experiment whether it got
hirevue camp oh I should check it I have
no IDE well you never know how you Tues
manipulating these things alright people
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
take literally one two minute break we
are gonna pour whiskey you always say
that we're gonna be water - do you have
to pee this time probably all right well
then depending on how long dr. Eric
Weinstein asked a urinate that will be
the length of the break we're gonna pour
some whisky on the rocks and then we're
gonna take some questions
so patreon.com slash rubin report we're
gonna give you guys preferential
treatment you can jump in on super chat
as well oh and by the way I'm gonna on
October 5th I am gonna be at wise guys
in Utah comedy doing about an hour of
comedy and there will be a special guest
from the intellectual dark web it's a
big one I don't want to say who you've
joined me pick you it can you I'm gonna
ask for a plug for my new YouTube
channel
oh and you're doing the YouTube and I'm
on Instagram because I'm getting I want
to diversify so that if I get kicked off
of Twitter for something I'm not
completely dependent on that point this
is sort of depressing so they did they
put out this alternative influencer
network about youtubers you've put up at
least three videos yeah you didn't get
on I'm a major youtuber man Eric's on
the on the youtube ways it just / Eric
our Weinstein or do you know what it is
I actually we're gonna find it we're
gonna comment on the video after the
livestream give us like two minutes
whiskey your questions patreon.com slash
rubin report will be our
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we are back
we've got whiskey first off cheers my
friend
Cheers let's see what happens well look
because of all the guff that Ilan took
when he went on Rogan tell everybody
it's not actually whiskey it's it's
ayahuasca it's ayahuasca that's right on
the rocks you wouldn't smoke weed on
camera would you pardon me
you wouldn't smoke weed on camera would
you all right here we go so real quick
we're gonna take questions from patreon
people first so Rubin select patreon.com
slash Rubin report we've got a whole
bunch of questions already we'll do some
stuff on super chat as well I will be at
wise guys in Salt Lake City on October
5th Dave Rubin calm slash' events and
the links in the description right down
below all right what us normies get is
that the very personal attacks against
famous people are a warning to the
normies not to step out of line do you
agree with this exactly yeah that's what
I've been pushing for a while now well
this is in terms of this network diagram
I just you know so this guy Cody Wilson
who had the 3d printable guns mm-hmm
defense distributed so I follow him on
Twitter mm-hmm and there was just an
ominous tweet which is like Cody Wilson
is followed by the following accounts
well I
Adolf Hitler if he were on Twitter need
to know what he's thinking I mean the
fact that you follow somebody if that's
evidence of your moral turpitude and how
bass and vile you are I mean for god
sakes if I was at war I would tune into
my enemy's broadcasts you can't tell
anything from that so this is part of
the scare tactics and I think that those
of us who are trying to be the advanced
guard and have to make fun of this yeah
so yes you're they are trying to scare
you that if you listen to these people
you will be radicalized you will be
unemployable and let us take the first
few steps and make fun of this and then
it would be great if you followed in
behind and made fun of us made fun of
not us but well they can make fun of us
that's fine they certainly do but yeah
that make fun of this mania about saying
well so-and-so talk to so-and-so talk to
so-and-so and I just want to say one
thing about this I haven't gotten to yet
yeah the whole concept of a safe space
is not about people being triggered that
I think is false I think what it is is
about safety for narratives and so if
you have a nonsensical narrative as you
do in any cult that narrative cannot
survive direct contact with outsiders
and so if you think about it it's right
funny that the institutions we are
actually a cult-like Network that aren't
confident enough of their opinions
I mean look I've never taken an econ
class in my life I want to tell people
that their calculation that the
calculation of CPI on a cost-of-living
basis with changing preferences is
completely wrong and I know how to do it
and my wife knows how to do it and so
far as I know nobody else knows how to
do it and if you want to come at me and
say that that's nonsense and this is the
the ravings of an amateur named the time
in the place I'll show up at any econ
department and make that argument that
kind of a narrative which is that you
have to have a secret group of people
adjusting the CPI because so much is
indexed to CPI so billions of dollars
change hand when you change the
calculation of CPI that's a nonsensical
statement and so you need a safe space
that says only the experts can
understand this that's the same thing
that we're seeing with so many of our
positions which is that people imagined
that the safe space is about not wanting
to hurt people's feelings no no it's
about not wanting these nonsensical
narratives to come into contact with
intelligent critics and I think that
people have to understand that you're
being warned away from PhDs from other
alternative intellectuals who have a lot
to say like Noam Chomsky because the
narratives are being
protected so a couple people have asked
me questions like this that I've gotten
before just now but I did get it here so
I'm just gonna sort of paraphrase it I
think you saw the moment when I had
Shapiro on a couple weeks ago and we got
into the gay cake thing again he said he
would not bake me a gay cake for my
anniversary party he said he may not
even come to my anniversary party and I
said my hope is that if we can remain
friends for 50 years I can move you on
this now I understand that I cannot be
friends with Ben exactly the same way I
can be friends with you because of that
particular issue we can be friends and
friendly and an allies in a lot of ways
but we there's a separation there for
sure but I do consider him a friend who
I have differences with and that's okay
and I want to respect his differences
and he's not trying to take away my
marriage or jail me or take away my
things as people keep telling me he's
trying to do I'm curious what you just
thought of that exchange just as
watching somebody talk about morals and
sin and how that's related to your
ability to be friends with someone yeah
I've got a terrible view on this I don't
know I I think Beth is actually being
very genuine in terms of the analytics
of it but I don't sense that he's got I
think it's a very formal homophobia as
opposed to a visceral homey homophobia
like okay there's some there's some
passage in in the Torah that says this
is not good and so well it says thou
shalt not lie with a man as you would a
woman basically but I don't lie with
women that way so it's all did you know
what I mean let's not make a big deal
yeah okay so focus the so I think that
Ben is actually being reasonable and you
know in the same way that as a guy with
a fair number of close game male friends
I know that there are some parties that
you guys feel comfortable inviting me to
and other parties that you wouldn't feel
comfortable in
fighting me too I'm not sure what yeah
I'm not having those parties you come to
any of my parties somebody who's named
yeah yeah not be known yeah your would
not be known to your audience yeah you
know once said to me if it's boy soup
and there are a lot of twinks running
around you're not going to be the one
getting the invitation and I hope you're
okay with that so that would be a kind
of discrimination that would be for my
benefit and I think that you know this
is what happens when Ben brings his own
food to the dinner party you're having
is he's trying to say how do i integrate
into your life in a way that allows me
to keep my Modern Orthodox position and
I actually really valued is real honesty
and I and I just I want to get something
across in Ben's defense which is yeah it
does seem kind of backward and on the
other hand it seemed kind of Awesome
which was that he was owning that this
was a discomfort that was no real bar in
my opinion to the depth of your
friendship and he's just gonna be formal
about it yeah and by the way if you hang
around with Orthodox Jews they there's a
lot of this they're very formal about
rules and they're also very adept at
getting around them and so this is
exactly what I expect from an Orthodox
Jew is that he is open minded in some
ways he's I think he's very progressive
on this front and he's gonna be up front
like formally I can't do these things
but it's very similar to when I have
Muslim friends in you know I have
Turkish friends in Istanbul and you're
having an FSB R and then you say hey you
know isn't it strange that you're a
Muslim and you're having this beer they
say you know I really shouldn't then
they put the beer down for the rest of
the meal or in India you talk about
people being confirmed bachelors that
are gay just give people their formal
out and that's the way that they're
dealing with their form formal
homophobia I don't think it's very deep
yeah and I just thought all these people
were like oh she rumored such a sellout
he's letty he's sitting there as someone
tells him he's a sinner and it's like
well then when they're ready to come to
the adult table we'll welcome there we
go all right
well we answered answered a couple of
there's a lot about just like how can a
business be built around this Eric I'd
love to see you have a discussion with a
free-market economist like Bryan Caplan
would you be interested in something
like that I've had Brian Kaplan on the
show he's a he's an AM Kap guy I really
I mean I like those ideas I just like
the intellectual place that those are
you know you'd be happy to do that right
I think so yeah why not talk to Tyler
Cowen a lot and Tyler and I disagree on
some stuff but you know it just as
people should know the universe of smart
generative people is so small that we
don't usually screen each other on
ideology we're just so happy to meet
somebody who's thinking deeply and is
open or just basically will act in good
faith as I go you think differently okay
it's all good I didn't know about this
maybe you did but how do you feel about
the nation of Hungary proposing to ban
gender studies as a discipline at their
universities had you heard about this no
I mean I think it's very important to I
would not ban gender studies I think I
would do what I just said which is make
sure that you have a uniform standard of
scholarship and not a form of
scholarship that is friendly to activism
you have to make sure that activist
scholarship is recognized as something
other than pure inquiry I mean are you
capable of disseminating a finding that
you're very upset to find that that's a
prerequisite for having professorial
privileges in terms of tenure and
academic freedom I did suspect there's
very little of that these days people
that truly go in without the sciences
there's tons of it yeah yeah and you
know this is my basic take on the
universities is that the heart and soul
of a great research university is its
hard core disciplines we've done much
more in those disciplines than anybody
else and so who are you and get out of
my lab is an important principle and as
long as we have something that keeps bad
scholarship from getting in from
you know bringing the principle of
explosion as we talked about before into
the sciences we should start exporting
scientific notions of rigor and we
should be holding debates between
disciplines to make sure that everything
is of a piece rather than saying okay
well you have no wage gap and you have a
wage gap we don't even know if it's the
same word so I think that it's a bad
move instead what we should do is we
should make sure that all of these and
by the way if Gender Studies has figured
out some things that the biologists
don't know we have to take our lumps on
biology it's not it's not a there's no
fix in that game do you have any
recommendations for having a more as
epistemologically honest responsible
conversation well I think that the ante
is much higher than people imagine that
one of the you know I think about I
don't know why I do this but I think
about the old shows Love Boat and
Fantasy Island there says Game of
Thrones and The Sopranos like the ante
is a lot higher these days we are smart
and we have long attention so you can
quick down Love Boat on my show I have a
thing for I carry a torch for Julie but
the cruise directors yeah I think that
people have to understand that if you
want to behave in a more epistemic ly
consistent fashion you're gonna need to
budget one or two orders of magnitude
more brain space because most of them
the heuristics that have been pushed out
are completely unworkable in our modern
world and once you open up that brain
space once you say okay I'm gonna follow
Game of Thrones for season after season
in episode after episode you're having a
much better time than you ever had with
shows that had to have their entire
narrative arcs conclude within 30
minutes mm-hmm and that sadly they did
that on Love Boat right like it's like
you got an hour we're gonna do some
we're gonna wrap this thing around in 40
minutes and there you go Eric what do
you think about a potential satellite
based internet solution because it seems
like ISPs are going to start banning
content over landlines I mean this goes
to all the technological
things that people are talking about
well right so you tell us how much you
want to persecute us and then you'll
cause the development of crypto and
smart contracts and satellites and it
can be free market guy I like it no I
just want people to be happy free market
okay
again there's a lot about that is there
anything to be done with social media
and funding platforms and payment
processors who are in the censorship
business it's sort of the same question
you can give me something on that while
I'm looking here look that there are
some very serious problems that the
major platforms are facing that we are
not facing and I think it's very
important for us to recognize that once
you break it you've bought it so if we
start our own thing there are going to
be all sorts of intellectual
half-measures that are gonna have to
happen so we're in a relatively
luxurious position riding on top of
somebody else's platform and they're
handling the problems I do think they're
gonna have to be innovations as I said
earlier there's something I forgot to
say that's very important that I'm just
gonna shove in here there's this talk
about whether or not Google is biasing
search mm-hmm oh I'm glad you're
bringing this let's really do this yeah
we should have done this in the first
part yeah my bad all right
Google is biasing search and the way in
which they're able to say we don't buy a
search is how they buy a search so
people need to look up ml fairness
machine-learning fairness Google is
released a video and they talk about
their need to unbias
search that's how the bias is coming in
is is the google is acting and I think
I've said this in a tweet as an
incompetent ophthalmologist you have a
very mild case let's say of astigmatism
or myopia and Google says oh my god
you're suffering from a terrible
nearsightedness yeah your eyeballs are
all misshapen here we're gonna give you
the craziest thickest glasses you can
imagine now you're blind as a bat when
you when you're putting those on but
from their perspective they're helping
you unbias your bias problem okay can
you just for people that haven't got
this can you explain why they think
biasing make sense sure it is definitely
true that physics let's say used to be a
much more European dominated male
activity okay it just is it was now it
is less so now but it is still very
often dominated by men who are fair of
hue right their perspective is well
that's a bias because in the past that's
what physicists looked like so if you do
an image search we should be correcting
for that bias so we're gonna show you
Neil deGrasse Tyson we're gonna show you
Stephon Alexander or James Gates and so
you know that they're showing you
African Americans and and then maybe you
know Shirley
it's her name Shirley Jackson black
female and so suddenly you're you're
saying wow this is really crazy I'm
doing the search on physicists and I'm
seeing all black faces or something like
this and so what they're doing is is
that they're claiming to undo latency
bias which is the data hasn't caught up
to the world that will be where things
are much more equal and so we've just
fit you with the prescription but you're
looking at this and saying wow you're
really biasing your data in order to
have a social justice agenda and so
whatever is going on with Donald Trump
is he's not saying the magic words
the question isn't to Google are you
biasing your data questions of Google is
are you unbiased thing you're doing tell
me how you're unbiased in your data and
the the phrase that pays is ml fairness
I should also say that anybody who knows
engineers within YouTube and Google and
all of these things knows that some of
them are very unhappy mm-hmm and some of
those very unhappy engineers are talking
about all of the ways that they're being
forced to degrade the product and to
privilege certain sources like I've seen
a list of rankings of various news
sources as to how authoritative they
should be and so the no no surprise very
liberal institutional media's and gets
very high rankings and
so from their perspective no no this has
nothing to do with politics it just has
to do with biasing authoritative sources
well that has everything to do it the
fact that you think it's authority
please just open this up so the rest of
us can can toggle these switches because
if you're gonna tell me I mean I I know
that a lot of things in the New York
Times happen to be true but I also know
that it has a very strong ideological
bias at the moment that's getting worse
and so I don't feel the same way about
privileges in the New York Times I think
this is something else that I want to
talk about there are no authoritative
sources that we can use as baseline at
the moment mm-hmm and it's a little bit
like having a dollar denominated fund at
a point when like the dollar is falling
or rising rapidly relative to everything
else if you are referencing yourself
like wikipedia says we accept
authoritative sources and then there's
some activists that gets into one of the
sources that they consider authoritative
and then wikipedia says okay well we
have to print this because it occurred
in an authoritative source that's why
the danger of letting the Sarah Jones of
the world in in there activist role is
because we now don't know what an
authoritative source is I would say that
there are no authoritative sources of an
institutional nature at the moment
because all of the institutions are
scrambling and quite frankly this is the
one thing that keeps me up at night and
the whole IDW concept was an answer to
the question from where will we reboot
when this madness is over like it's not
going to be from departments in
universities that have been taken over
by activism or news organs or political
parties it's going to be from
individuals and I think that the thing
that is most authoritative right now are
the individuals with a lot of surface
area who are pretty trustworthy do you
think there's a cut-off point for the
individuals who are the good guys inside
I'm not just talking about the the
average person right now for the people
that are inside that get it but that are
cowards right now and maybe for good
reasons there's a coward that are acting
cowardly no no or that are there
for a litany of food reads there I don't
wanna say yeah I'm just gonna okay so
you know I'm a little more frustrated
with these people because they privately
come I know but you know what the thing
is yes it how many nights do I wake up
in a cold sweat like oh no what's going
on you know it's a okay so when they
come for you yeah and they're you know
it's it's merciless and it's life
destroying so I don't think these people
are cowards
take on the level of risk that you can
afford to take on if you've got two
really young kids at home and you're
just getting by and a gig economy thing
don't do it
don't stay at some level safe enough
that you can meet your obligations but
if you happen to have as Joe Rogan says
f you money I've had idea that's not it
needs to be more than just the F you
money people know if you have a little
bit of a few money you don't have to be
you don't have to have eight figures of
wealth if you're in a position where you
have very few dependents and you know
you uh you do GoPro videos with extreme
skateboarding on weekends you're already
taking major risk get in here help us
out don't be a [ __ ] about it you think
there's a cut-off point though for
certain people like once we fix things
and if you didn't get on board two more
qur'an's private truths public lies
because the idea is you have some number
of people who are willing to go first
and then you have some people who are
willing to take on slightly less risk
but they're really right in behind you
but the thing is is that we need more
people evaluate your risk if you can
afford to join us join us that's the
point but look there are people who
there are people who are being cowardly
they have all the advantages yeah but
they won't step up those those are the
ones that I'm prior I do it's not the
average person yeah I don't want to
antagonize our our people who are saying
like you know you know when I hear if I
lose my job how do I provide for my
children I mean you get of course and
I'm not talking about those currently
you know when when there was a there was
a dinner we got into where it got pretty
heated because there was a certain set
of very wealthy Hollywood people that
are down with what we're doing and they
won't do it publicly and it's like and I
was the one that was pretty it's what
Morpheus says
you know he says I'm not gonna lie to
you everyone who has ever faced an agent
you know has met their end but sooner or
later somebody's gonna have to and when
it's time you'll be able to okay well
you have people who are going to try to
fight the agents first and the least you
can do is don't undermine the people who
are taking the risk yeah
in order to sell them out to feed them
to the crowd right so don't be safer
right because you think it gives you a
little more time or so right but but in
general if you don't have a lot of
obligations and you've got a little bit
of change in your pocket you don't need
that much get in here and help ya date
if you ever had to have tosh point-o on
the show seems like a guy who benefits
from free speech I don't think we have
tried I will look into that oh I like I
like this one for you because this is a
very Jordan Peterson question Eric I
have a three-month-old how do you raise
a responsible critical thinking son in
this polarized postmodern world of
bananas first of all do something like
Peter thank you at least some hand
motions little this no Jordan Jordan on
me all right you know I kept my son off
of social media just introduced him on
my channel and Zev has just opened his
own his own channel so check that out
the thing I did was I took my children
as seriously as they deserved to be
taken as soon as they were ready and I
was astounded really at how quickly a
smart child's mind comes online ready to
deal with things and I think I remember
when was Sandy Hook no it's over two
years ago now it's maybe it was there
was a school shooting and I talked with
the children about risk extensively and
they weren't that disturbed because they
had an intrinsic sense that the odds of
anything happening in their school were
quite low but that there is no guarantee
and you know if I think back on all of
the crazy conversations I had with my
two children a daughter and a son
be prepared that it's not just children
say the darndest thing children are
ready for much more adult interaction
while still being there adorable
childlike selves and don't be afraid if
you find yourself in a conversation that
you can't believe you're having with a
three or four year old both of those
happen with my children I remember when
I was away I taught myself to play the
Vivaldi Largo movement from a guitar
concerto and my daughter said I miss you
daddy and she said listen to this and
she related it on violin so I knew she
wasn't getting it from sheet music and I
just thought like okay what your your
five your six I don't remember what what
age your children are going to astound
you take it seriously and don't treat it
as if it's adorable treat it as if it's
serious well said there's a lot of
Peterson style questions here you want
to keep going on that whatever you want
all right if what Peterson has said is
true that we're living in a 13 year old
girl's reality and most of the people
who want a deep platform the IDW are
possibly emotionally stuck is attacking
their ideas directly effective at all or
is there any value in starting an
emotional discussion it goes on a little
bit more from there well it's well go
for that I think that and this is
something I said at the end of our
performance in New York on that panel if
you can if you're in a position to love
your opponent out of their cult do that
you don't have to always return costs
and assume you know very often you're
dealing with frightened and scared
people who don't realize that they're
much more resilient than they think
they're stronger the world isn't as
hostile people form completely insane
ideas about what they're up against and
you know I remember my de facto uncle
Mike Brown who used to invite us on to
unto his island up in Washington State
I think was a Republican not positive he
was like the kindest most generous
person I could imagine and people who
came to the island who had very strong
left-of-center ideas had this idea that
somehow Republicans were all selfish I
can't tell you how common that believes
and I'd have to point out you realize
that your host is providing everything
for you and it's just the kindest best
person who give you the shirt off his
back is voting in a way that you would
think of as selfish because he wanted
low taxes and he believed that this was
the best way to help people out of
poverty is to give them self-reliance
try yeah I I really believe that in some
sense set an example and try to show
people that who they think they're
dealing with isn't who they're dealing
with
have you guys discussed the possibility
of this movement becoming a third
political party is that actually even
possible well we sort of hit on there
should be a third political party I
think it should in fact both political I
think our system of selective pressure
is determined by the Constitution more
or less selects for two parties whether
it's Democrats or Republicans or the
wings come back doesn't matter the key
thing is that we we on the Left need you
on the right to be responsible and you
need to know you have a party on the
other side and I think that was the
magic where Ben Shapiro after the joint
appearance came to me and he said you
know Eric the thing that I fight on the
left is these claims that the market or
society is all off and he says when you
come in with a highly specific complaint
about some aspect of the market or an
oppression or something like this
he says I'm absolutely willing to listen
and I thought wow this is how we do it
is is that we the left takes out its
garbage on the extreme left the right
takes should take out its garbage on the
extreme right and you'll start to see I
think been for example engages in a
certain amount of lib baiting that he'd
love to stop and it's really targeted on
the extreme it's not targeted on the
center and I think he would come in so
the center of left
and right needs to go fight its own
wings that are polarizing everything but
the IDW doesn't live in one party and
it's not a separate party when it is is
an agreement about what constitutes a
conversation and what constitutes a
legitimate argument and part of the rap
against us is is that we're snowflakes
and that we don't want to talk to people
who think things they're very different
from us
in a weird way I think we don't want to
talk to people who have really novel
ideas about what constitutes an argument
because we have a clear idea of what
constitutes an argument and everybody is
willing to submit ok you got the better
of me
you know I remember a particular moment
where Sam Harris got the better of me in
my first podcast the key thing that that
we don't like is when you just make up
your own logic you're not entitled to
your own logic and you're probably not
entitled to your own facts and you're
probably not entitled to just go off on
your own epistemic ly inconsistent
tangent to get all the goodies once you
meet some some of these criterias I
think we'll talk to more or less anybody
who's got a decent heart and a desire to
figure out what would generally be seen
as best for society but it should be
having both the left and or right I'm
not interested in it becoming a third
party I like that you call it an
agreement I don't think I've ever heard
you say that before I like that all
right so we're gonna take a couple more
on Rubin select it's patreon.com slash
Rubin report and then we're gonna keep
drinking whiskey Eric what do you make
of the metaphysical implications of the
big bang not a lot well give me one more
sentence on that sure when you solve
Einstein's equations there are two
essential singularities that you
encounter one is the black hole
singularity that you associate with a
collapsing star and the other one is the
Big Bang the initial singularity that
you associate with the beginning of the
universe and really in some sense what
they tell us as mathematicians and I'm
going to take some guff for saying this
but is is that Einstein's equations
aren't the final are at the end of the
story because they probably wouldn't
have these defects if you will and so
there's the big bang that occurs with
respect to you know
the moment of last scattering or however
you want to think about what we can
observe and then there's the initial
singularity which has to do with the
Einstein equations and in general you
don't want to make metaphysical
inferences around the points of your
model which are least reliable and so
wait just for the simple ten on this one
so if so the argument would be that if
it was if these were perfect theories
that the Big Bang and basically
wormholes wouldn't wouldn't exist not
Wormold but but like black holes a
quartz chilled singular yeah yes that's
what the argument is yes that that those
are the signs that you're not done yet
got and so the problem is some people
become very attached to the idea that
they should be investigating those four
metaphysical implications but likely all
your work is going to be wiped out when
a better set of equations becomes
available if you're trying to make
metaphysical meaning out of that so it's
super tempting and the reason to do it
would be that you wanted to push the
equations so hard that they broke so you
could find the true ones that doesn't
bother me at all but don't spend too
much time thinking about something in a
system pushed beyond its domain of
reliability all right here we go two
more because we got some stuff to do
tonight I'm just a regular dude other
than daily exercise of basic critical
thinking what is the role of regular
dudes like me improving the quality of
sense making amidst the corrupted
institutions you've been discussing the
regular guy not the [ __ ] you money guy
first of all I don't I've never met a
regular dude my belief is that everybody
has something extraordinary in them so
first of all stop stop claiming you just
a regular dude unless it's your false
modesty and then the question is if
you're already here asking these
questions and you're a patron of the
Rubin report think about yourself is
already in a tiny minority and take on
some goddamn responsibility for where
you want to steer this thing and and ask
for help if you you know pick up an oar
and start rowing man all right one more
I'm gonna say I'm gonna go to super chat
this is Tim Poole do you know Tim by the
way I've never met him all the way
he's reached out to me yeah so Tim is
doing great work he's actually an honest
journalist on the graph he's new he's on
the graphs I'm like I'm a freakin dead
center of the graph and from what I
understand Tim Poole reactionary
journalist I can hear laughter yeah yeah
yeah well we know what part we're using
is the promo now Timmy Poole the
half-korean white supremacist it's all
so stupid but Tim and also by the way I
think for the record if I'm not mistaken
some of the connections that they
actually had to Tim don't even exist and
a bunch of other stuff okay Tim said in
super chat they know they're lying about
our views this is the death rattle of an
archaic media system we we didn't really
talk about their bad intentions enough I
think perhaps because I think you you
always and I try to I try not to judge
Piazza's intentions he's going right to
their intentions here they know they're
lying they know what they're doing they
know they're lying and they think that
they're doing it in the service of
something beautiful
yeah well then the problem is just the
reason I'm left off of this graph with
this white supremacist Korean Tim Poole
and again I'm sorry about that I noted
if they would have asked I would look I
kind of grew another brother everybody I
was I was too busy trying to organize
Nuremberg style rally the reason that
they leave us off is because they can't
handle the fact that you have like a
Bernie supporter who's never voted
Republican in the supposedly reaction I
mean they're going after Tim Poole like
children and they're trying to find
something that sticks all right doesn't
seem to work extreme right reactionary
this that yeah
let them empty their revolver because
they don't really have many bullets left
yeah yes they don't they know that
they're lying but they think they're
lying in the service of good and I might
lie in the service of good if the good
were extreme enough and the lie were
small enough so don't get upset with
somebody just because they're lying in
the services but of course they know
they're lying and of course
they think they're doing it in the
service of good but the point is we're
going to have to live with each other as
a nation and we're gonna have to love
each other and there are a lot of people
with this mimetic complex in their mind
this is why I went and I talked to Kanye
I thought what Kanye was gonna do was D
Trump off' i mega with people who wanted
their towns in Ohio and western
Pennsylvania to start working again
people who you know we're drinking
themselves silly feeling that they were
part of the American Dream and got
sidelined we are going to have to find
common closet it's just not that hard
you know it's just not that hard to have
a friend whose hue is different than
yours it's not that hard to have a
friend you and I have serious political
differences at this point it just
doesn't cause me to want to silence you
know and so my claim is is that even
though they're lying and even though
they know they're lying
you've got to experiment with love and
forgiveness to the best of your ability
and I can't tell you that I never lash
out I think I lashed out a little bit at
Rebecca Lewis because she was lying she
said it will never not be funny that the
entire intellectual dark web is only
located on YouTube oh really so the 12
rules of life isn't a book that exists
and the waking up podcast isn't
something that has no video even if it's
it exists on YouTube people listen to it
off of YouTube is it it's not true that
we don't have any event of course
Rebecca Lewis is lying she knows she's
lying data in society is lying these
people all know that they're lying but
they think that they're lying for some
beautiful reason to keep our country
together to make sure that we're not in
the hands of a tyrant to make sure that
every child has a shot at a beautiful
tomorrow and I'm sorry that they're this
confused but have some compassion
because they don't have the compassion
when we hear about empathy okay
the onus is on us they don't have this
great empathy they like I so care about
trans people that I can't care about
white people okay
gives me a headache you're either
empathic and you care about people in
general yeah
or you it's selective empathy and you
really have a lot of hate in your soul
so I set a goddamn example that that's
my basic take which is you've gotta love
the people who are lying thinking that
they're advancing the world's cause and
you have to love them out of their cult
and if we're not willing to take that on
then I don't know what we're doing but
yeah I can't always make this this high
bar that I'm setting for myself I will
fail I lash out at somebody but have a
forgiveness narrative there's in general
no redemptive redemption narrative on
the left that's why it's not even a
religion people say it's a cult it's
religion without a redemption narrative
there's nothing if what you're really
excited about is sticking it to the man
whoever the man is you're not
fundamentally a good person you're a
person who's working through your own
personal anger and so my claim is is
that love the people who are lying
against you and figure out what an
incredible power incredibly powerful
weapon that is because at the end of the
day after you knock them senseless to
the pavement you better offer them a
hand up and say look it wasn't personal
it's just you were you were threatening
our system and you know I felt like I
couldn't communicate to you while you
were still in the cult that's where I am
I'll join you on that adventure my
friend Ohio there you go all right guys
that's it remember October 5th wise guys
in Salt Lake City
we've got your links you do have a
custom name by the way for your own
youtube channel I'm gonna it's gone it
was here before it's up its up top
ah it's Eric our Weinstein on Instagram
and if you just search Eric Weinstein on
YouTube it's on there Dave Rubin comm
slash events for a bunch of more
stand-up stuff that I'm doing and we're
going to Europe with Petersen and a
whole bunch of other stuff and
patreon.com slash rubin report we're
trying to get our Reubens select members
to 5000 people we got a great community
growing over there you want to get
dinner or something sounds like a plan
alright that's it see ya
[Music]